When we talk about energy storage,
we're often talking about one thing: the battery.
Try to imagine a world without them.
You'd have no mobile phones, no laptops,
tablet computers
or even remotes
for your TV
I think batteries are amazing,
but they can be very very familiar.
So I wanted to show you an unusual,
and slightly in fact I think quite scary,
demonstration of what batteries can do.
So I've rigged this up.
This is an arc welder.
Not something I thought I'd be doing
It uses electricity to cut through solid metal.
It's one of the most energy intensive
processes you can think of.
The actual tip here can reach
20,000 degrees Celsius
and that extractor fan there is
going to actually take up the fumes.
But the welder is hooked up to just
a couple of ordinary car batteries
and come with me
and I'll show you what they look like
So right here are some two ordinary car
batteries and we've hooked them up.
But we've put them out here because
there's a small chance they might explode.
So let's try and set things up.
So I'm no welder,
I'm just a humble chemist,
but I'll be happy to give it a go.
So this is my hand in glove,
and so it's really important
at this stage right
before I get down here,
so if you can put your goggles on now.
I tried something earlier it wasn't a
fantastic effort
Right, let's see if that's better than my
first attempt
Well let's have a look so
if you look here I tried to do Ri twice.
I don't think I'll give up my day job
and become a welder.
So I would say that's my
abstract period
and that's my sort of dodgy period.